i
[Música]
se busca la reconciliación en colombia
las autoridades de bogotá convocaron un
acto para pedir perdón a las familias de
las 13 personas muertas y a los cientos
de heridos que dejaron varios días de
protestas contra la brutalidad policial
que derivaron en más enfrentamientos con
las fuerzas de seguridad tenemos reporte
desde la capital
más de seis meses en que la organización
mundial de la salud declarara al hobbit
19 como una pandemia desde ese 11 de
marzo los gobiernos latinoamericanos
reforzaron medidas y restricciones
sociales que han impactado la economía
de la región
hoy américa latina es la zona más
afectada por la crisis sanitaria en el
mundo
los rusos votaron en unas elecciones
regionales cruciales para el partido del
presidente vladimir putin y que quedaron
empañadas por la ausencia del líder
opositor alexéi navalni quien fue
presuntamente envenenado cuando hacía
campaña electoral en siberia
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria empezamos a colombia donde
las autoridades de bogotá pidieron
perdón a los familiares de los
fallecidos en los enfrentamientos al
margen de las protestas que comenzaron
el miércoles tras la muerte de javier
ordóñez bajo custodia policial en las
que algunos manifestantes incendiaron
decenas de estaciones policiales el
presidente y bando que no acudió al acto
a esta hora se celebra una vigilia para
las 13 víctimas mortales allí se
encuentra nuestro periodista luís muñoz
lluís que resalta de lo que lleva esta
jornada
estamos aquí en bogotá en el park way
ahora tendría que estar comenzando a las
seis el tercero de los actos organizados
por la alcaldía de bogotá de claudia
lópez consiste en una velatón y también
en un cacerolazo en memoria de las trece
víctimas que tú que murieron el 9 y el
10 de septiembre cuando hubo
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
policía para destacar que en por lo que
se ve en el ambiente parece que tanto
ayer como hoy ha descendido la
intensidad del conflicto y por lo que
vemos aquí en el parc güell en un
céntrico parque hay como un ambiente más
festivo a un lado hasta la policía
custodiando una de las estaciones de
policía que fueron incendiadas tanto el
miércoles como el jueves y al otro lado
tenemos a gente que estaba concentrada
con música bailando también los vecinos
han organizado han creado una biblioteca
popular para resignificar este lugar y
darle otro otro significado después de
los hechos violentos que sucedieron por
parte del gobierno también ha habido
reacciones el gobierno ha dicho que en
caso de que se demuestre que hubo un
exceso de fuerza conductora los
manifestantes con él
de armas de fuego habrá que tomar
medidas drásticas sin embargo hay
también parte de la población que
critica esta jornada de perdón y de
reconciliación
primero porque consideran que aún no ha
habido los funerales de las tres
personas fallecidas y por otro lado
también porque consideran que estamos en
un momento en el que el hecho de la
reconciliación no es un buen momento
ahora mismo después de todo lo que ha
sucedido
bien bien luís muñoz pues vamos a seguir
pendiente contigo del desarrollo de esta
jornada en la capital colombiana en
bogotá con luís muñoz y vamos ahora con
noticias del coronavirus y es que el 11
de marzo se declaró pandemia al cob y 19
y al rebasar los seis meses diez de los
diez países más afectados a nivel global
en términos de contagios cuatro son
latinoamericanos brasil perú colombia y
méjico las naciones ya iniciaron cada
una a su manera procesos de reapertura
vemos este informe de santiago ariztía
seis meses de pandemia y restricciones
sociales ahora a la crisis económica se
suma el hartazgo en muchos sectores de
la sociedad hace meses brasil se
mantiene como la nación más afectada de
américa latina'
el gigante latinoamericano acumula más
de 4 millones de contagiados a pesar de
las estadísticas prácticamente todos los
estados siguen adelante con sus planes
de apertura bites a pandemia ha durado
más de seis meses y nadie puede
soportarlo más
méxico es el cuarto país latinoamericano
con más contagios pero el segundo a
nivel de decesos con más de 70.000
fallecidos no obstante seis meses de
paralización en muchos sectores de la
economía llevaron a una recesión cercana
del 13 por ciento si me espantan las
cifras pero un poco quedarme en casa la
verdad mi economía ya no me lo permite
no me lo permiten no no puedo pero es
uno de los casos más preocupantes con
casi 33 millones de habitantes y más de
30.000 fallecidos es el país con la tasa
global más alta de decesos pese a las
cifras alarmantes en esta nación rige
una cuarentena focalizada que muchos
aseguran que no se respeta
otros de los países latinoamericanos en
el centro de la atención es colombia los
casos superan ya los 700.000 pero
septiembre comenzó con una nueva etapa
de flexibilización en las restricciones
si bien las cifras no son lo
suficientemente alentadoras seis meses
de paralización de sectores
fundamentales
sumados a los cambios en la rutina
derivaron en una reapertura ansiada por
muchos bolsillos y mentes
nos vamos a rusia y es que ya cerraron
las urnas en las elecciones regionales
que son vistas como una prueba de la
popularidad del partido de vladimir
putin aunque estas votaciones no son tan
importantes como las parlamentarias
nacionales de 2021 si miden el pulso
entre el presidente y la oposición que
encabeza alexéi navalni el activista que
según alemania fue envenenado durante
esta campaña electoral vamos a este
informe de mar y aclara la calle
en unas elecciones empañadas por el
envenenamiento del opositor
alexéi navalni rusia acudió a las urnas
para elegir gobernadores legisladores
regionales y concejales del partido
oficialista rusia unida tienen la
mayoría de los parlamentos regionales
pero la oposición aspira a quedarse con
varias sillas especialmente en siberia
con la municipalidad universitaria de
tomsk y con novosibirsk la tercera
ciudad más importante de rusia y donde
navalny antes de ser envenenado lideraba
un esfuerzo por sacar los funcionarios
del partido de vladimir putin con una
estrategia llamada votación inteligente
en la que promueven cualquier candidato
que no sea oficialista
para cada uno de los 27 distritos de
toms que seleccionamos un candidato que
recomendamos por lo que ahora una
persona puede ir a nuestro sitio
ingresar su dirección registrada y ver a
un candidato que recomendamos esperamos
que este sistema de votación inteligente
funcione pero además de la ausencia de
la principal figura opositora los
comicios están manchados por denuncias
de irregularidades al pasar de 1 a 3
días de votaciones si la estrategia de
votación inteligente funciona la
oposición espera llevarla a las
elecciones legislativas nacionales del
próximo año aprovechando el descontento
social en aumento causado por las
denuncias de corrupción y abuso de poder
y por lo que algunos rusos consideran un
mal manejo de la pandemia del cobi 19 y
mire para finalizar hoy empieza la
semana de la moda de nueva york un
evento icónico para esta industria y que
por primera vez se realizará con
desfiles virtuales debido a la pandemia
y estamos con una de las protagonistas
ella es la diseñadora boliviana rosita
hurtado
muchas gracias por esta comunicación
señora hurtado la pandemia ha modificado
la alta cultura de diversas formas
que algunos diseñadores incluso
diseñadores como usted se han volcado a
producir más cariz platícanos más de
cómo ha impactado el coronavirus su
industria mira hola muchas gracias
gracias a la invitación efectivamente en
este momento está comenzando mi
participación digital del new york
fashion week y este vídeo junto a mis
colegas diseñadores de moda a apoyar a
la industria de la moda ya que el
impacto ha sido bastante grande como
decía tuvimos que cambiar todo y hacer
mascarillas yo tengo una fundación ha
donado muchas mascarillas durante 5
meses de la pandemia y bueno comenzamos
a hacer como dior también el fashion
week' de mayor porque es algo que
tenemos que verlo como cómo seguir
adelante lo no podemos quedarnos
en shock como hemos estado durante este
tiempo y no seguir con el apoyo que nos
ha dado la oportunidad de presentarlo
virtualmente que ha sido un
inconveniente para nosotros porque hemos
tenido que producir todo lo hoy bajo los
patrones de seguridad que nos han dado y
reducir modelos reducir también las
salidas de vestuarios el equipo de gente
las autoridades ya prácticamente todos
nosotros antes era muy fácil porque
llevamos sólo la colección al avión y la
organización se encargaba de brindarnos
todo este servicio pero con todas las
dificultades lo hemos hecho y seguimos
adelante con el apoyo a la industria de
la moda señor hurtado nos quedan 40
segundos para que cierre esta emisión
pero sí le quiero preguntar que está
presentando esta hora en la semana de la
moda en nueva york que se viene en esta
temporada
mira yo estoy presentando una colección
de alta costura con trajes con telenoche
que se denomina arco iris es una
colección con colores vibrantes trajes
de cóctel noche y también alfombra roja
hago muchos trajes de alfombras rojas
bodas
y eso es lo que han presentado en esta
colección yo pienso que uno tiene que
ser fiel a su estilo y seguir haciendo
esto lo que es una propuesta de
temporada que es para la siguiente
temporada
21-22 es la alta cultura no tiene
estación de invierno por lo tanto son
trajes de primavera-verano muy bien pues
muchas gracias rosita hurtado diseñadora
y un orgullo latinoamericano muchas
gracias por esta comunicación gracias a
ustedes siga con más en france 24
[Música]